celui qui
les gens ne voient comme une bête soit
en barbare
lui le plus brutal
et le plus impitoyable champions et n'y
a personne comme toi y a personne qui
peut égaler mon style louanges à la ga
prévisible ma gardien finira bien trop
féroce je bouffe aux gamins que
j'arrache des coeurs je suis vraiment ça
je t'ai donné la vie et sur la pente
savonneuse d'agos qui va finir en taule
[Musique]
alors prépare-toi
salive mike
mais c'est trop mal famés ça a été ma
chance l'espoir de mon sang
et mohamed ali maintenant c'est devenir
le plus jeune champion du monde de
l'histoire awad
que ce soit le boxeur le plus méchant
que la guerre ait jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas envie d'évoluer
ils vont admirer autant qu'ils vont te
craindre
vaut mieux que tu continues à gagner
parce que toujours tu vas perdre un peu
bas ce mec va te foutra coup de pied au
cul
je te parle de postérité
trouvons gravé dans le marbre pour les
cabines
[Musique]
besoins des tribus du cepr et n'importe
quoi qu'il arrive à l'histoire d'en
sortir
la ministre du contrôle place isolé
soit jamais
mais soit
n'était pas un choc qui s'affairait
faire
[Musique]
mais je suis qui maintenant quand je
suis devant vous
[Musique]